-Our next guest stars
alongside John Cena
in the new hit film
"Vacation Friends,"
which is streaming now on Hulu.
Please welcome Meredith Hagner.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Meredith Hagner ♪
♪ You cannot pretend ♪
♪ Things just might get freaky ♪
♪ With "Vacation Friends" ♪
♪ Meredith Hagner ♪
♪ I know that she could ♪
♪♪
-Yeah!
-Yeah! Hey!
-Ahh!
-You're here!
-I keep wanting to give also
my attention to The Roots!
-Of course.
The Roots right there.
-You guys are so awesome.
-Yeah, you have to.
-Hi, Jimmy.
-Meredith, I'm so happy
that you're here on the show.
You look gorgeous.
Thank you for coming
to the show.
-Thanks for having me.
-This is your first time
on the show,
but apparently
we've -- we've met before.
-Yeah, it was really huge
for, I think, both of us.
No, I --
I met you when I was 16.
-Uh-huh.
-And I was a huge Strokes fan.
Like, arguably the biggest
Strokes fan in the world.
And my dad dropped me off
at the Ritz Theater.
I went by myself to a show
when I was 16.
So it was like 1942,
somewhere around there.
And you opened for The Strokes.
-That's right.
-Yeah.
-I opened --
Did you know who I was?
-Yeah.
-Okay, all right.
-I was a huge fan.
No, you were really funny.
And I was like,
"Who's this guy?"
I have a photo of you
in a white track suit.
-Yeah, I used to wear white
Juicy Couture track suits.
-Which I was --
I was really into.
And then, I was like --
I got my little T-shirt,
and I was waiting by the,
you know, area in the back --
What is it? The --
-Yeah, backstage.
-Backstage.
And -- And I was waiting
for the band to sign it,
and I had my T-shirt out,
and you came up and signed
my shirt,
which was really nice.
-Oh. See?
-And so people would be like,
"Oh, did The Strokes
sign your shirt?"
'Cause I wore it, like,
every day of high school.
And I'd be like,
"No, the guy that opened did."
-Yeah, the guy who --
I don't remember his name.
Jerry Falcon."
-Yeah. "Jerry Falcon did."
But then, so many people
asked me who it was,
and I had to say "Jimmy Fallon."
So I think I'm really
responsible for your career.
-Wow. Yeah, you -- Thank you.
I appreciate that.
-Enough people
in North Carolina heard,
and now you're here.
-North Carolina. The Ritz.
That's what I'm talking about.
I shall return.
I do remember opening up
for The Strokes.
We opened up for them
for six shows.
And I just did --
We had, like, comedy music.
And I was so excited, because
I love The Strokes, as well.
-Yeah.
-And no one wanted to see me.
No one wants to see a comedian
open up for a band.
-I mean, it's a tough one,
'cause people do go
for music, specifically,
so you're already starting --
-We did some gigs where people
would just scream,
"Get off the stage!"
And I was like, "So, you guys
go to the movie theaters?"
Just doing my stand-up
or whatever.
I'm so happy, though, that you
saw that and had a good memory.
-A really good memory.
-Thank you
for coming on the show.
I want to talk about --
There's so many things --
I want to talk about
your hit Hulu movie.
But, also, you and your husband
just recently had a baby boy.
-Yeah, we did.
-Congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thanks. Thanks.
-And we love Wyatt.
I love Wyatt Russell.
I love him.
Please give him my best.
How old is the baby?
What is the baby's name?
What's he like?
-He's amazing.
He's 8 months old.
-Aww.
His name's Buddy Prine.
We love him.
We named him after John Prine,
who we're huge fans of.
And, yeah --
It's funny, 'cause I was --
Not that I wasn't a baby person,
but when people --
When I would see newborns,
I was kind of like, "Yeah."
-Yeah. You're like,
"Okay, yeah, yeah, sure."
-And then when I had him, like,
I was truly convinced he was
actually the most beautiful baby
that had ever been born.
To the point where I was
almost embarrassed
for us in the hospital.
People would come in.
I'd be like, "It's insane.
I know."
-"I know. It's insane." Yeah.
"We actually have the most --
yeah, the best-looking baby."
-And I look back on photos,
and I'm like,
"No, he was a newborn."
-He looked like a baby, yeah.
-He's awesome.
-This is your first time
away from baby.
-Yeah.
-How's it going?
Are you --
-I slept for 15 hours.
-Yeah! That's what
I'm talking about! Really?
-This should be required
for new moms.
Glam and 15 hours of sleep.
-And this. And you.
-Oh, good.
-But also the sleep.
-Obviously people know you
from "Search Party."
-Mm-hmm.
-Congrats on the great reviews.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But now, here you are,
doing this new film,
"Vacation Friends"
with John Cena,
and it is the biggest
film opening --
original movie
in Hulu's history.
So, not bad,
making a little history.
-Thanks. Thanks.
-It's a huge hit.
-Yeah.
-And I heard
that it's just announced
that there might be
a sequel being made.
-Yeah, we got a sequel,
which is so amazing, right?
Yeah.
-That's gigantic.
-Thanks. I'm -- I'm geeked out.
-I mean, that's great.
We know John and Lil Rel,
as well.
-They're the best.
-They're just fun on set.
-Oh, unbelievable.
Like, they're both
such comic geniuses.
-But you're pretty
brilliant yourself.
-Thanks, man.
-Can we set up what
"Vacation Friends" is about?
-Yeah.
It's a film about two couples
that are very --
They become very --
They're unlikely friends.
John Cena and I play, like, the
couple you cannot get rid of,
that you meet for like five
minutes and you're like,
"They were nice," and then
you just can't lose them.
-Yeah.
-But it's a really fun movie.
I think it's --
it's a good feel-good --
Reminds me of,
like, old-school comedies
in a way that's refreshing.
-Yeah.
That's what we kind of want
right now.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Meredith Hagner
in "Vacation Friends."
Take a look at this.
-Get comfortable.
Oh, and if you guys are worried
about privacy and you want to,
like, get really kooky tonight,
we're extremely loud.
I don't know what these walls
are made of,
but you seriously
can't hear anything!
Okay. Listen.
[ Doors close ]
[ Screams ]
[ Doors open ]
You're not gonna believe this.
I just screamed in there.
[ Laughter ]
-Meredith Hagner, everybody.
"Vacation Friends"
is streaming now on Hulu.
-Thanks, guys.
-Congratulations
on Baby Buddy Prine.
-Yeah.
-I love that.
-Thank you.
-Baby Keem performs for us
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
Thank you so much.